trust they say it takes years to earn
and only seconds to break and forever to
repair for u.s mainstream media those
seconds have turned into months of
nose-diving viewing figures amid a
crisis of confidence on saturday a top
cnn reporter ridiculed reports of supply
chain disruptions by taking a pop at
average joe
the supply chain she exclaims looking
for milk for a two-year-old look at this
amazing overflowing abundance he
responds
such contempt from u.s media for the
current difficulties faced by so many
has led to widespread condemnation with
many americans bemoaning an out-of-touch
media that is alienating its own
audience
i don't see a thing therefore this thing
must not exist this person calls himself
a journalist
can't wait to hear a third person
commentary on gas prices
everything is fine in my bubble of
reality
if milk is 300 percent the price it was
two years ago but wages have only gone
two three percent and inflation is
outpacing growth abundance doesn't help
also please rename your show to
literally anything that doesn't have the
word reliable in it it's false
advertising so the chasm in
communication between the public and the
press is widening major channels like
msnbc and cnn have seen their respective
prime time spots nosedive by just under
half of their total viewership but it's
not just the democrat liberal media
that's losing touch with its base fox
news viewership is down a third from the
same period just a year earlier now back
then the media consistently found
ratings thanks largely to donald trump
but in the biden era that's all changed
not so long ago buzzfeed learned the
hard way about dwindling audiences when
the company laid off a third of its
staff but not only buzzfeed all u.s
traditional media have faced a
year-on-year decline which has led to
tens of thousands of media jobs being
wiped out the media sector announced the
highest job cuts on record in 2020 this
industry which includes television and
movie production news and advertising
announced 30 711 cuts this is 201
percent higher than the 10 201 cuts
announced in the sector in 2019. and
while traditional media continues to
report on an agenda rather than covering
issues at the heart of society that
trust wears ever thinner and ratings
plunge ever further perhaps by reining
in their reporting bias just a little
mainstream media won't just be doing
their view as a favor but also
themselves as well